من الخرطوم ينضم الينا المتحدث باسم الجيش
السوداني اهلا بك معنا في هذه التغطيه
المباشره والمستمره للمعارك القائمه في
الخرطوم وانحاء السودان سعاده المتحدث
يعني كيف هي مجريات الحرب الان
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وكل عام وانتم
بخير وانت بخير
عمليه الكرامه الوطنيه التي يعني بدات
مذيعهم
بدات بشكل حاد وكما تابعنا
بمقاولات كثيره ومتعدده من المليشيا
المتمرده
للسيطره على المقر العسكريه ومقر القوات
المسلحه وبالتركيز على القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه ما جرى ان هذه العمليات
خلفت ادب كبير من الدمار في بعض المرافق
الحكوميه وكذلك ما يؤسف له ان هنالك
مدنيين
في هذا الوضع الانساني الحارج سيدنا نبيل
لماذا ترفضون اي هدنه مع الدعم السريع في
هذه الايام ومن الذي ومن الذي ومن الذي
القوات المسلحه في الحقيقه ثلاثه
ووافقت عليها القوات المسلحه جميعا وكان
شرطنا الوثيق هو ان يلتزم على الجانب
الاخر
ما تنص عليه هذه الهدنه من اي من توقف اي
تحركات عسكريه وعدم استخدام السلاح وعدم
استخدام الرمايه القناصه من اسطح المباني
التي نشروها في محيط الخرطوم وفي وسط
الخرطوم ومريحيط بالقياده العامه وفي بعض
الاحياء السكنيه في وسط الخرطوم الخرطوم
اثنين ومناطق اخرى متفرقه نحن اعلنا فورا
في الثلاث مرات موافقتنا على هذه الفتنه
للجوانب الانسانيه ولكن الذي ينته انه منذ
دقيقه الاولى لا يلتزم الطرف الثاني بهذه
الغنه فهو اما
لارتفاع ذاته في المناطق السكنيه التي
يمارس فيها اسوء انواع المعامله للمواطنين
من تفتيش وقتله للناس ونهدي للممتلكات
العامه واخذ لاموال الناس وهم
يعني
في العقل الزمري السوداني في المواطنين
لهذه الممارسات التي توجه مباشره الى
الشعب السوداني هنالك امر انا اريد ان
تفضل اليه انه طوال هذه الايام والسبعه
للهرب لم يسقط اي مواطن سوداني عيار طائش
القذيفه للقوات المسلحه لاننا
ركزنا كل جهودنا في الفتره الماضيه في
الدفاع المحيط القياده العامه هو محيط
القطر الجمهوري المناطق التي هم كانوا
يستهدفونها وكنا نقوم بالتصدي والرد على
هذه المحاولات وهذا ما رايناه في مروي يا
سيدنا نبيل يعني بالفعل راينا حسم للمعركه
وراينا اطمئنان للمواطنين هناك وراينا
ايضا احتفالات بالعيد حتى رغم الحزن ورغم
الاسى الاستراتيجيه التي استخدمت في مروي
هل تطبقون ذات الاستراتيجيه في الخرطوم ام
في الخرطوم هناك استراتيجيه مختلفه
مدير هذه المعرفه الاستراتيجيه واضحه
ورؤيه واضح
ه هي صحيح
النرضى ان تكلفنا الكثير من الشهداء
وتكلفنا حرق لبعض المقرات العسكريه او
الحكوميه ولكن نحن
واستراضياتنا ان نمتص ونحتوي كل هذه
الهجمات وان لا نوسع نطاق هذه العمليه الا
عندما نتاكد تماما ان التداعيات توسيع هذا
النطاق لا تعرض المواطن السوداني تعريض
مباشر لايران القوات المسلحه لانه لا يمكن
ان نوجه نحن سلاح ونحن نشك في انه قد يقع
في منزل او يقع في مواطن او بسبب اي نوع
من انواع الخساره وفي ظل كل هذا الحرص من
منكم او من الجيش سيد نبيل بان لا تتعرضون
لاي من المواطنين بالتالي اين ترتكز
المعارك او ما هي خارطه المعارك على الارض
في الخرطوم تحديدا
اول اول
التحشيلات التي جرت من قبل قوات المليشيا
المتمرده منذ اكثر من عامين كانت
بجوار المواقع العسكريه وما في قلب
المدينه قلب المدينه في وسط المناطق
المعقوله بالسكان كل القوات التي حجدونها
بل ذهبوا اكثر من ذلك هم قبل هذه الاحداث
اليوم او يومين حاولوا ان يفتحوا قواتهم
في المدينه الرياضيه المدينه الرياضيه
التي تقال حي المطار وتتوسط احياء في
الخرطوم هي الازهري وحي الانقاذ واحياء
الجريفات وهذه القوات اصلا هم وضعها وسط
المواطنين ذهبوا ايضا الى ان يفتحوا
القوات كبيره جدا على امتداد شارع النيل
حتى منتزه المقرن العائلي في مقابله القصر
الجمهوري وقاعه الصداقه وما وراها المناطق
هذه هي قلب العظمه كانوا حريصين جدا ان
يفتحوا قواتهم في هذه المناطق لتتقرب من
الاهداف التي هم رصدوها
على السلطه ويسيطروا على الحكم في هذه
البلاد ويضع البلاد امام مواقع يفقدونه
بالقوى
اعذرني على المقاطعه ولكن اريد ان افهم
منك مجريات المعركه حول محيط القاعده
العسكريه تحديدا ومحيط المطار في الخرطوم
كيف تجري اليوم الان اثناء حديثنا
الان اليوم
لم تكن هنالك اي معارك في محيط القياده
العامه
توقفت عده هجماتهم تماما نتيجه للتصدي
القوي والثاني الذي واجهناهم به وهم الان
الامر الذي يؤثر على هذه المنطقه انهم
فتحوا مجموعات كبيره من القناصه على
البنايات العاليه التي تطل على شهر
افريقيا وفي الخرطوم اثنين سواء كرتوني
بالمناسبه هو مقر يعني قديم كان رئاستهم
قرار قبل 2017 طيب ماذا عن جنوب الخرطوم
سيدنا نبيل
وهنالك مناطق في شرق النيل اشتروا بنايات
اشتروا مباني واخرى وضعوا يدهم عليها
الوضع في جنوب الخرطوم سيدنا نبيل
الوضع في جنوب الخرطوم ايضا في المنطقه
حتى امتداد
يعني عندما يفرغوا من محاولاتهم القياده
العامه والقطب الجمهوري مجموعات كبيره
منهم تنتشر في هذه المناطق وصولا الى
منطقه صوبا والباقير طيب نبيل في 30 ثانيه
المتبقيه لدي متى برايك ستحسم المعركه
من الصعب جدا من الصعب جدا ان حدد زملا
معينا هذه العمليه مع التقديراتها خاصه
وحرب المدن نفسها هي ان تصنف كعمليه من
العمليات الخاصه وهي عمليه فيها شيء من
التحقيق
لان ميدان او متعادله العمليه هو
الامتدادات السكنيه والمناطق المعقوده
بالسكان الامر الذي يتطلب ان
تحسب فيه التحركات دقيقه وان تعالج فيه
يعني هذه المسائل بحكمه وصبر شديد واحيانا
مضحي نحن باهداف معينه حتى نحقق يعني اكبر
الحمايه لمواطنين في هذه المناطق يصعب ان
يحدد لك زملا قاطعا في الانتهاء هذه
العمليه لكننا ننزل كل ما في صنعاء وننزل
دهوت كبيره لان مصفي
وهذه الجيوب الموجوده في اقصر وقت ممكن
لنخرج من هذا الفابوس وهذه الازمه الكبيره
طيب
التي خلقها تمر هذه طيب سيدنا نبيل يعني
في ظل الوضع الانساني الصعب ما شروطكم
للهدنه هل يمكن ان نرى فتح ممرات امنه
قريبا هل يمكن ان نرى دخول مساعدات
للمتضررين والمستشفيات
على ان تمر هذه
المسائل الانسانيه
سيدنا نبيل شرطنا ان يتوقفوا تماما اولا
ان يرفعوا هذه الاقتصادات التي وضعوها
ثانيا ان يحدوا تماما من هذه التحركات
ثالثا ان يتراجعوا عن المواقع التي فتحوها
في وسط المدينه وفي قلب المناطق السكنيه
وان يتقيدوا تماما
بانزال القمامه في عمليات القمص العشوائي
التي تحدث على مدار الدقيقه كل يوم منذ
بدايه هذه الاحداث ونحن
شكرا لك من الخرطوم المتحدث باسم الجيش
السوداني سيد نبيل عبد الله الانضمامك لنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات